foreign
thank you
come down
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome to the table my name is Don
Jacobs I'm glad that you guys could join
us uh this tonight and before we get
started I do have a few announcements
um we are kicking off we've got a lot of
things going on it is like Easter is
around the corner
oh absolutely absolutely so so a couple
of things we've got going on and they're
thankfully they're all happening like
right here so next Sunday is going to be
our Palm Sunday
um celebration we got something kind of
special planned so make sure you don't
want you don't want to miss that it's
going to be fun excellent everything
like that normal time everything nothing
changed
um after of course the following Friday
is going to be good Friday so it's going
to be our service also here uh 7 P.M
please join us for that and then of
course the following Sunday is Easter
yay
absolutely absolutely
we're going to be having a sunrise
evening sir uh no Sunrise morning not
evening goodness gracious Don Jacobs
we're gonna have a sunrise morning
service so we're going to be here at
eight in the morning which is going to
be very different for our crew because I
know that's not what we normally do so
we are gonna have to set the alarm yes
you know get to bed early at decent time
on Saturday you know all those things
can try to do normal Church like the
rest of the world and then wake up at
you know and get here at a decent time
and all that kind of stuff but
um because it's so early all that kind
of stuff kids just bring your kids PJs
are totally fine just pull them out
let's go uh we're gonna have a
continental breakfast you don't even
have to feed them before they walk out
the door okay just kind of pull them out
of the beds and just let's go
um because again we know it's gonna be
kind of kind of early we're going to try
to accommodate as best as we possibly
can
along with that so because of all the
stuff with kids kids so kids ministry
needs some donations
um they're going to be doing an Easter
egg hunt and all that kind of stuff it's
gonna be fun fantastic for the kids but
we do need some donations so if you
wouldn't mind if you could please please
please give us some eggs would be
helpful uh candy would be helpful all
that we would need it for sure by next
week I know it's kind of a quick
turnaround but please do that for first
but next week get with Maggie if you
need some additional details with that
so
yeah and there she is absolutely there
she is amazing Maggie there she is one
quick last list
um last announcement so there is going
to be a new small group that is going to
be starting next month so after all the
Easter hoopla is kind of coming to a
close this one's to be focused on prayer
it's kind of a kind of interesting to
have a short very targeted
um kind of like a mini series like three
sessions specifically focused on uh
being reflecting and on a practices of
prayer and just being mindful when it
comes to those practices and it's going
to be led by Johnny Horton so yeah
and so so get one there if you want some
details on that but um the first state
is
um April the 18th I believe excellent
they say we just get where third with
some additional details for that all
right that's a lot of information it
will not be a quiz afterwards
but um do you want us to kind of relax
kind of get in the mode I knew we have
been kind of gotten here World rush
trying to get things over here but let's
just kind of chill relax we're gonna
start I'm gonna start you off with
prayer we'll get started with the
worship
Laura thank you so much for each
individual person in this room thank you
for our online community who's joining
us also as well
um no matter where we've been this week
the highs the lows just all the things
that we have on sitting on our weight
and our shoulders I pray that you just
allow us just to be able to have
experience some level of Peace here in
this space
help us open up our hearts and our minds
to worship to the words are going to be
shared later on
um in Christ and I pray amen
thanks Don all right you guys I invite
you to stand with us we're going to get
going
um and the set this week I just as I was
putting it together just felt
um kind of drawn to going back to some
songs that have really defined some of
our values as a community
um I see a couple of table shirts around
that have our values written out on them
but things like inclusivity things about
being thoughtful and communal vulnerable
so I hope you hear some of those themes
As we sing through these songs they're
just ones that I have felt like are true
on any given week Any Given Sunday
regardless of what we're talking about
these things are always going to be kind
of our focal point the things that we
anchor ourselves into so
um I just invite you guys into that
space with us feel included and enjoy
going in as we as we kind of think
through these messages and songs I know
we have several of our normal community
members who are out of town this week
and I was kind of coming into today
thinking like there's this old song that
says we are few but we are strong when
you surround us and and that was going
through my mind but as I look out I'm so
excited to see some faces I've never
seen before so I just want to welcome
you guys into our worship you are fully
welcome here with whatever you brought
through that door so you guys just join
in all right
[Music]
through every
circumstance
I believe that you are my Fortress and
you are my portion
you are my Hiding Place
[Music]
I believe
all right through every blessing
whoever we promise
through every breath I take
I believe
[Music]
it's a New Horizon and I'm set on you
you meet me here today
all my fears and doubts
they can all come to because they can't
stay long when I'm here with you it's a
New Horizon and I'm set on you you meet
me here today with mercies that are new
all my fears are Downs
[Music]
the life I believe
I believe
[Music]
it's a New Horizon and I'm set on you
you meet me here today with mercies that
are new all my fears and doubts
they can all come to because they can't
stay long when I believe you I
thank you guys kiddos can you go and
stand beside the door wait for your
teachers okay let them enter before you
so they can give you instructions our
preschoolers go over here to this store
and our elementary kids and above are
over here
foreign
[Music]
so sorry the kids ministry gave me this
nice Note to read and it's my phone is
not processing it so I'm sorry kids
ministry I'll read it next Sunday
it is like do you want to download right
now
sorry Maggie
um I am so grateful for our kids
ministry workers and thank you guys for
making space for our kids in this first
song
um really our heart behind behind our
church in general is just that our kids
would feel fully included in the body of
Christ and we don't want two churches
where we have kids shut behind walls and
we only see them after the service is
over we want them to feel like they are
fully integrated in us I was raised in a
church that did an amazing job of making
children feel like people not like
little things that we're trying to get
rid of and I hope and pray that we can
become a community that is calling our
kids to be part that it's a learning
from our kids incorporating them into
our service so anyways if it's your
first time here and you're wondering
kind of how we do things that's why we
have our kids in this first song just so
that someday when they're out of school
and they're sitting in these rows it's
not going to feel like a foreign place
to them it's going to feel like a place
that they grew up in so
um thank you guys for making space for
making room for them
I know sometimes it can be hectic and we
have parents having to Corral and but
it's worth it it's so worth it because
they are worth it
um we're going to move into the prayers
of the people
um Eden is going to lead us in that this
Sunday so you guys read along with Eden
and then we will have space for
um anyone who's carrying a situation or
a person on their heart just to lift
that up together as we carry that and
then
um we'll finish out the prayer go ahead
Eden
sassy Texas and for every city
and
all of those who live in them we pray
The Good Earth that you have given us
and the wisdom and the will to
conservatives we praise to you for those
who travel on land sea or air we pray to
you for the old and the sick the Widow
and the orphan for the injured and
suffering we pray to you
for the unemployed
the poor and oppressed the unemployed
and destitute for prisoners and captives
and for all who remember and care for
them we pray to you Lord we know that
you love us and that you hear us and so
we lift these names and situations up to
you
[Music]
good
for the names and moments we have spoken
aloud and for those we have kept in our
hearts we pray to you that they may have
life and Light
healing and Hope peace and a deep sense
of your presence amen
foreign
[Music]
All The Broken Pieces of their heart
blessed are the tears
[Music]
like a sky falling stars
wants anymore
brave enough to show the Lord their
scars
blessed are the hurts that
[Music]
are open to the
Church of God
the kingdom is yours
hold on a little more this is
Hope is in the Lord keep your eyes on
him
[Music]
blessed are the Deeds
blessed are the ones who fight for
justice
longing for the coming days
yes it is
[Music]
[Laughter]
hold on a little more this is
[Music]
yours
hold on a little more this is
[Music]
oh
the ones who suffer
violence
and still have strength to love their
enemies
and blessed is the faith that those who
persevere foreign
[Music]
hope is in the Lord keep your eyes
hope is in the Lord keep your eyes on
him
[Music]
foreign
we do keep our eyes on you
God even when we're unsure of what's
coming
when the world around us seems shaken an
unsettled God
we focus in on a love that does not give
up that does not go away
a love that is faithful and true
even at our worst God
and we believe that you're doing a good
work
and we trust you to continue that God
would love be our anchor
[Music]
and in my mother
is
[Music]
doing
nothing
you make all things work together
for my future
and for my
goodness
We're Together
For Your Glory
and
for your name
[Music]
is
has been wasted
[Music]
you make all things work together
for my future
[Music]
work together
for my future
[Music]
I know nothing has been wasted no
failure or mistake you're an artist
[Music]
you're welcome
finished with me
[Music]
you're not finished with me
and you make all things
work together
for my future
and for my goodie make all things
work together
For Your Glory
and for your name
[Music]
this week I'm going through a lint study
right now and a verse that kept
repeating each day of of this week of
Lent was Jeremiah 31
says I've drawn you with unfailing love
with Everlasting kindness
and um
it was so powerful for me this week as I
kept going back to that verse
um
because I can have a pretty strong
voice in my head of just my my inner
critic is pretty loud and
um
and it can and it can approach songs
like this and and um
it's easy to recall the things that
where I've missed it or the
disappointments the failures even the
things I didn't have control of the the
things that
um the prayers that didn't get answered
you know and it can look on those things
pretty critically at times where it can
be hard to find God in the middle of it
but that verse just kept anchoring me
into just this reminder of the kindness
that I'm continually met with every time
I come back to Jesus every time I look
back towards the cross every time I
remind myself of the story of the Gospel
it's a God who meets me with unfailing
love
Everlasting kindness
it's a God who even when I couldn't make
sense of the circumstances when they
seemed too painful to possibly walk
through he was there
patiently waiting
extending Grace
giving me strength it was a love that
didn't run out
even when I felt emptied of any love
that I had to muster up on my own
there was just this source that carries
us
and I just
God I pray that whatever it is that
we're facing whether it's our own
critique of ourself our shame our guilt
our regret
or whether it's circumstances outside of
our control
that have left us jaded and disappointed
and hurt God I pray that tonight we will
begin to find you and your love woven
throughout our story that we would begin
to sense the moments where there was
kindness that was unexplainable
where there was Grace beyond our
imagination
where there was hope when all we saw was
Darkness
God would you keep drawing us with
everlasting love and kindness
would it meet us at every turn
cause you're not finished
you don't abandon the work of your hand
you are faithful and just to complete it
so would we give you that space in that
room that permission in our lives to
keep doing your good work of Ashes to
Beauty
would we be able to say that those
things are true about us and about our
story
thank you for who you are
thank you for your grace and your
kindness
it's in your name that we pray all these
things amen
would you guys turn and greet the people
around you make them feel welcomed and
then tonight we have a special guest
bringing our message
I don't know
all right so I get the honor and
privilege of
um welcoming our speaker up here it's
really funny because Denise has been as
those of us who know her I mean it's
just kind of like an extension of the
family so there's not really a lot I
could share because she's she's just
always been a very welcoming to us
um obviously with you know the space
that we have
um inviting us to some of you know her
Church's specific ceremonies and
services and things like that opening
doors for us things like that and so
it's not really so for those of us who
kind of know it we kind of know Denise
she's she spoken and shared with us
before so I started thinking as like
what can I share
about Denise really and I started
thinking I was like wait a second do we
do have visitors
so for specifically for our visitors I
know that sometimes walking through
a door into a church space is kind of
nerve-wracking
um especially if they're in the of us
which was probably a lot of us in a room
who any kind of survived any type of
church trauma there's always a little
bit of like I'm not sure who I can let
in I don't know how much I can trust I
don't know if I can be myself here or be
vulnerable Denise is not one of those
people
Denise is amazing she has one of the
most gentle most loving hearts
I mean I love her to Pieces
um so she is a great person and you can
most definitely trust her so for that
being said
welcome to these we can't wait to hear
from you
thank you thank you
Doug I'm so thrilled thank you so much
for having me
um
I'm always thrilled to come here and
speak it's just it's such a joy such an
honor and I'll tell you that last week
Brett came and spoke in my church and he
gave a knock it out of the ballpark
sermon so I feel a lot of pressure
tonight so he was fantastic I hope you
all know how great he is he is just so
great and my congregation loves him and
I'm just
I think we just have sort of sort of a
mutual thing between all of us so I'm
really glad to be here thank you the
scripture that I've chosen for tonight
is taken from First Corinthians it is
chapter 1 verses 18 through 25.
hear now these words
for the message about the cross is
foolishness
to those who are perishing
but to us who are being saved it is the
power of God
for it is written I will destroy the
wisdom of the wise and the discernment
of the Discerning I will thwart
where is the one who is wise
where is the Scribe where is the debater
of this age has not God made foolishness
the wisdom of the world
for since in the wisdom of God the world
did not know God through wisdom God
decided through the foolishness of our
proclamation to save those who believe
for Jews demand signs and Greeks desire
wisdom but we Proclaim Christ crucified
stumbling block to Jews and foolishness
to Gentiles but to those who are called
both Jews and Greeks Christ the power of
God and the wisdom of God
for God's foolishness is wiser than
human wisdom and God's weakness is
stronger than human strength
this is God's word for us today thanks
be to God would you pray for pray with
me and pray for me too
Come Holy Spirit
May the words of my mouth and the
meditations of our hearts be acceptable
in your sight
our Rock
and Our Redeemer
amen
so many of you may not know but I'm a
mother of five children grandmother to
ten and when my our three oldest
children were little we spread them way
out but when our three oldest were
little
um my husband Mike worked for American
Airlines
so one day he was working in finance but
anyway our son Nicholas was out playing
in the yard and the neighbor's son came
over and suddenly Nicholas came running
into the house and he said Mom what does
daddy do at work
I said well he helps run the finances of
the company well Nick look at the little
confused but
frankly he didn't really know what Mike
did and I really didn't know what Mike
did either so I said it means he makes
sure that the planes can keep flying
that there's enough money to pay the
pilots and the flight attendants and
everybody that works for the company
oh okay said Nick and he ran outside and
he came back in pretty quick and I asked
him what happened where's your friend
oh he went home
why
well he was mad
he told me his daddy was a pilot and I
told him that my dad was probably his
dad's boss
so he went home
my dad's better than your dad
although he was just a child I think
we're all looking for that little
something aren't we that gives us power
over somebody else something that puts
us just slightly above some another
person
in our country we talk about the
American dream if you just work hard
enough well you can just achieve
anything
what we mean by that though is that you
can become wealthy and with wealth comes
power
we live in a world that's obsessed with
power and wealth ask any child what they
want to be when they grow up and when
they're little they'll say Batman or
Superman
now when my granddaughter Violet was
about four
she said she wanted to be either a
princess or Darth Vader
I said well Violet why a princess or
Darth Vader and she said well princesses
are pretty
and they can get people to do whatever
they want them to do
she said Darth Vader isn't pretty but he
makes everyone do what they wanted what
he wants them to do now you can tell by
that that Violet is a middle child
power is something that everyone seems
to covet don't we
so much so that the magazine Forbes
releases a list every couple of years of
the most powerful people in the world
since it's kind of difficult to quantify
power well the editors explain that they
compile the list taking four criteria
into consideration
does the person have influence over a
lot of other people
does the person have control of
relatively large Financial Resources in
comparison to their peers
is the person powerful in multi-spheres
I'm sorry multiple spheres and in other
words do they have power in more than
one area and lastly does the person
actively use their power
well I'm sure you won't be shocked
to wonder well you might wonder how many
people are on the list or 75 people out
of um but in 2018 there was only slots
for about 60 and who was on that list
well I'm sure you could yes
XI J ping the liner uh the leader of
China and probably pronounced his name
wrong but that's okay Vladimir Putin
and former president Donald Trump of the
U.S and Jeff Bezos of Amazon
there's nearly 7.5 billion humans on
planet Earth State the editors at Forbes
but these 60 men and women make the
world turn
see the old adage says that money makes
the world go around but the truth is
it's power
that makes the world go round money is
just as a necessary vehicle for gaining
power
and power is necessary in this life
those who study these kind of things say
that the human desire for power is
rooted in self-preservation
no one person or Nation wants to be last
in the pecking order right because if
you're last well you're probably not
going to live very long
if you do manage to survive well
you probably will be somebody else's
servant
or slave
or Whipping Boy
we all want to climb up in the pecking
order because the higher we go the
better our chances you see are for
survival
and the higher we go boy the more
freedom we have
freedom to do what we want
to make life easier for ourselves or
those we care about
freedom to live life on our terms to to
have control over our own destiny
we all want Power don't we
but how do we get it
well power is only Power if somebody
else recognizes it right
if we want to have power all we we have
to prove it in some way that we are
powerful so the U.S proved that in World
War II with the bombing of Hiroshima and
Nagasaki Joseph Stalin proved it in the
USSR with a killing of over a million
dissidents and what was known as the
great Terror
on a lesser scale well power is proven
every day in our lives by those who
employ us they can fire us or
if we don't comply by our government if
we don't pay our taxes we can go to jail
and even by parents do what I say or
else
power is only Power
it's backed up by something
some kind of consequences
strength
it's the way the world works right like
it or not
but into this truth which we all
acknowledge
explodes this paradoxical message
of the cross
a message which I gotta say for a lot of
us has lost its meaning
there are very few places we can go in
this world today that we won't see
across somewhere right
every church has a cross we've got tons
of them here
usually outside and inside
we focus on the cross as a symbol of our
faith faith during worship we make the
sign of the cross sometimes to remember
our baptism we sing happy songs about
the cross at the cross at the cross
where I first saw the light and the
burden of my heart rolled away it was
there by faith I received my sight and
now I'm happy all day
cross jewelry is everywhere
crucifixes that depict Christ dying and
agonizing death
beautiful filigree gold and silver
necklaces cross earrings bracelets and
even cross toe rings
the cross tattoos
cross t-shirts
crosses on leather jackets and even
Bejeweled crosses on the back pocket of
jeans
we decorate our houses with pretty
little crosses we have cross-shaped
pinatas
we use Sea designers using crosses in
their clothing lines
for both the religious and the
non-religious well the crosses become
kind of a fashion statement of some some
sort it's everywhere it's on everyone
it's every in and everything we're so
used to it
that when we hear the words of Saint
Paul in our lesson for today we're at
best just a little bit confused
the message about the cross is a
stumbling block to Jews and foolishness
to gentiles
how
is the cross a stumbling block for
anyone
how is it foolishness
to understand what Paul is really saying
here we have to go back
over two thousand years ago it's about
to the time of the Roman Empire this is
an Empire that is founded on the
cultural value of Honor
honor was everything so much so that an
honorable death was far better than a
dishonorable wife
this is the culture
that introduced crucifixion to the world
a form of execution that was intended to
inflict the optimal amount of pain on
the uh on the offender but more
important it was designed to degrade and
humiliate
the offender to shame them
this form of execution was considered to
be the ultimate the the Supreme Roman
punishment reserved for the worst of the
worst it was considered so dishonorable
that the average Roman citizen avoided
even talking about it
it was considered so beneath a person of
Honor that even Cicero a Roman
philosopher and politician who lived
just before the time of Jesus said that
the very word cross
should be far removed not only from the
person of a Roman citizen but from his
thoughts his eyes and his ears
the very mention of crucifixion is
Unworthy of a Roman citizen and a free
man
the practice was so distasteful that the
the word the very word crucify was
considered to be a vulgar word
ancient documents describe a prostitute
who has tried for swearing at one of her
patrons and the word she used was go get
yourself crucified
we have a modern equivalent of that
don't we
it was dishonorable
and it was extremely effective
the famous teacher and writer
quintillion described the purpose behind
the practice when he said when we
crucify criminals the most frequented
roads of the conquered lands are chosen
where the greatest number of people can
look at and be seized by fear
for every punishment has less to do with
the offense
than with the example
The Condemned would be forced to carry a
rough Hume being beam of wood as they
walked down the road
they're the powerless people would would
either cower in fear or cheer as a
condemned struggled by they would taunt
them they would throw things at them
they would spit on them giddy with the
knowledge that they weren't on the
lowest rung of society
giddy with the knowledge that they had
escaped such a fate
when The Condemned reached the execution
site well the beam would be attached to
a post or even a tree where then they
would be hung arms outstretched
sometimes for days
until they died in excruciating death
usually of asphyxiation
it was horrific
it was an image of great shame
an unknowable death
a symbol of contempt proof of conquered
nations of just who
was in charge proof two conquered
nations of just who was in charge it was
a terrifying reminder
of how impotent they were
in the face of the Great and Mighty
Roman Empire
see for people of the time using this
cross as a symbol of faith well it would
have been like African Americans in the
Deep South in the of the early 20th
century placing a beautifully woven
noose at the front of their churches
or like the Jews of 1940s Poland placing
a miniature golden gas chamber
around their necks as jewelry
it's unimaginable
isn't it
yet it is this symbol
the this message of the cross that Saint
Paul says this is where we find
power
of God
no we want to shout no the power of God
is in the empty tomb it is not in the
cross
but Saint Paul says Jews demand signs
and Greeks desire wisdom but we Proclaim
Christ crucified
although we often use
the word Christ as Jesus's last name
Christ is not a name it is who he was
it is the Greek word for messiah for the
anointed one for King Paul is telling us
that the good news we Proclaim is that
this man Jesus
is the Christ the Messiah the promised
King who has come to bring about God's
kingdom God In the Flesh and this God
King has died on a Roman cross
executed in torturous pain and shame and
oppression in utter weakness
this message of weakness of
powerlessness of defeat
is where we find God's power
how in the world does this make any
sense
God looks foolish Paul says
get in this foolishness
we find great wisdom
God is weak
it is only in this weakness that we find
power no wonder the Jews couldn't
stomach it they couldn't get past it no
wonder the Gentile thought it was
absolutely crazy
because it's shocking really isn't it
it turns everything we think we know
upside down God brings about salvation
for the world through a crucified Christ
God the creator of all that is seen and
unseen rescues humanity and all of
creation from sin and death through the
execution
of a humble and non-descript King on a
Roman cross
it's shocking that in this one act
God defeats
our greatest enemies
our greed
our pride
our selfishness all those things that
push us to hurt others and harm creation
Jesus overcomes the sin and death by
bearing the brunt of our sin and giving
himself up to death
you see it's as if Jesus
on the cross absorbs into himself all
the hatred all the violence all the
guilt all the shame the pain the
suffering all that humans can inflict on
one another
he absorbs it all
instead of fighting violence with
violence instead of fighting Power with
power like everyone expected a king to
do or even a God to do Jesus just
absorbs it
he takes on the shame and humiliation of
all who are outcasts all who believe
they're unworthy all who are powerless
and in doing so shows us that God is on
the side of the shamed not the shamers
of the humiliated and the isolated not
the bullies or the powerful
in this act you see Jesus shows us who
God really is
God is the god who would rather die than
kill
who would rather love than condemn
The God Who would rather suffer by our
hands than impose his will on us
Jesus shows us that God is a God who
answers violence and hate with radical
forgiveness and unending mercy
a God that takes on our sin who suffers
for us who suffers with us and a God who
will never abandon us
God's wisdom is revealed
not in power
but in weakness
not in glory but in suffering not in
hatred and violence but in love and
peace
and for those of us who are being saved
God's power is found
Saint Paul says in this one act
it's a really shocking message isn't it
but my friends it's good news
it's good news for those of us who live
in this world for those of us who live
with the power of of force and
intimidation
for those those of us whom the world
seems to have left behind for those of
us who suffer or grieve or somehow just
don't measure up in the eyes of the
world it's good news
for those of us who are racked with
guilt this evening
those who were overcome by shame for
something we have done because you see
this the message of the Cross says God
is not standing over us condemning us
God Is Standing before us With Arms Wide
Open
ready to forgive ready to welcome us
home
and that's really good news
for those of us who felt abandoned by
God
for those of us who think that God only
works in God moments
those times when something spectacular
happens something miraculous something
extraordinary because the cross you see
shows us
that God also works when tragedy strikes
when the worst things we imagine can
happen
when pain and suffering and despair and
even death hits us
these moments can sometimes be the most
powerful God moment as God comes
alongside us
and walks with us
through Darkness
and disaster
see the cross shows us that God is Not
unmoved
by the ebb and flow of human
circumstances and human experiences
God is Not oblivious to our hurt
God is right there
in the midst of it ready to walk with us
through it
to give us just what we need day by day
to make it through
it's good news you see because the cross
shows us that when God seems silence
silent when all things seem to be lost
well that's the time that God is doing
God's best work
the message of the Cross is where we
find God's power
it's the place we find God's wisdom
it is in this cross
that we place our hope
our faith
because this cross you see is where we
find the heart of God
in this cross
we find unending love
love Beyond of all measure
amen
in the name of the father and of Son and
the Holy Spirit
my friends I have been given the great
honor of
presiding over Holy Communion tonight
we have much the same
I'm gonna put this over here we have
much the same um
understanding of communion
in the United Methodist Church we serve
an Open Table anyone is welcome no
matter who you are no matter where you
have come from no matter where you're
going this is a place for you because
this table does not belong to anyone
Church
this table is the TR is the table of
Jesus Christ
and the one who died on the cross for us
welcomes all all to come
I have a liturgy that we do
um and I'm gonna a lot of it is reading
but some of it will be on the
screens and you can just follow along
with with me there's a part in here
where I'm going to sing and it's going
to sound intimidating but that's okay
just sing back exactly what I sing to
you there's there's nothing magical
about it
so we start with our invitation and then
we do a confession and a pardon so my
friends Christ Our Lord invites to his
table all who love him who earnestly
repent of their sin and seek to live in
peace with one another
therefore let us confess our sins before
God and before one another
merciful god we confess that we have not
loved you with our whole heart
we have failed to be an obedient church
we have not done your will we have
broken your law we have rebelled against
your love
we have not loved our neighbors and we
have not heard the Cry of the needy
forgive us we pray us for joyful
obedience through Jesus Christ Our Lord
amen
my friends hear the good news
Christ died while we were yet sinners
that proves God's love towards us
in the name of Jesus Christ you are
forgiven
glory to God
amen
in my church we now do what we call
sharing of the peace and I thought it
might be nice we as I always tell my
church it's not greet and meat it's
peace of Christ be with you
we're told they come to the table with
no uh no enmity between us
and sharing the peace is that way of
saying I don't care what happened before
In This Moment let there be peace
between us
let Christ be the space between you and
me
so the Peace of the Lord be with you
and also with you you can take a moment
to just
say peace of the Lord with people right
around you
peace of Christ be with you peace be
with you amen
amen
so the Lord be with you
lift up your hearts
let us give thanks to the Lord our God
it is right and a good and joyful thing
always and everywhere to give thanks to
you almighty God creator of Heaven and
Earth
and so with your people on Earth and all
the company of Heaven We Praise Your
Name and join in their unending hymn
holy holy holy Lord
holy holy Lord God of power and might
God of power and might Heaven and Earth
are full of your glory
highest
blessed is he who comes in the name of
the Lord
that is he who comes in the name of the
Lord Hosanna
in the highest
[Music]
you did well
holy are you o God and blessed is your
son Jesus Christ by the baptism of his
suffering death and Resurrection you
gave birth to your church you delivered
Us From Slavery to sin and death and
made with us a new covenant by water and
the spirit
on the night in which he gave himself up
for us our Lord took bread
he gave Thanks To You O God
he broke the bread gave it to his
disciples and said Take and Eat This is
my body which is given for you do this
in remembrance of me
and when the supper was over he took the
cup he gave thanks to you gave it to his
disciples and said drink from this all
of you this is my blood of the New
Covenant poured out for you and for many
for the Forgiveness of sins
do this as often as you drink it in
remembrance of me
and so in remembrance of these your
Mighty acts in Jesus Christ we offer
ourselves o God and praise and
thanksgiving as a holy and Living
Sacrifice in Union with Christ's
offering for us as we proclaim the
mystery of faith
Christ has died
Christ is risen
Christ will come again
pour out your Holy Spirit on us gathered
here and on these gifts of bread and
wine make them be for us the body and
blood of Christ that we may be for the
world the body of Christ Redeemed by his
blood
by your spirit maketh one with Christ
one with each other and one in Ministry
to all the world until Christ comes in
final Victory and we Feast it as
heavenly banquet
through your son Jesus Christ with the
Holy Spirit in your holy church all
honor and glory is yours almighty God
now and forever
amen amen
[Music]
now with the confidence of children of
God let us pray together the prayer Our
Lord taught us to pray Our Father who
art in heaven Hallowed be thy name thy
kingdom come thy will be done on Earth
as it is in heaven give us this day our
daily bread and forgive us our
trespasses as we forgive those who
trespass against us
and lead us not into temptation but
Deliver Us from Evil for thine is the
kingdom and the power and the glory
forever
amen
my friends since there is one loaf we
who are many are one
we all partake of the same loaf
and the cup over which we give thanks
it is a sharing in the blood of Christ
but those who are assisting sir please
come forward
you get one tree but before you take it
let me serve you for a second
August
the shed for you
we can go and take them now
you want to just give me a piece of
bread
okay my friends
we've got the wine on each side so you
can just come up through the middle and
we'll
back that way
foreign
[Music]
we're going to close out today with a
song it's called find the light by David
Ramirez I don't know if any of you are
fans of David Ramirez but
um I know Jesse is
and if Maggie and Brett were in the room
they would be giving a little shout out
to one of their favorites and I have to
confess that Maggie had asked me if she
could be on stage when we did this song
and not
so can y'all pretend like I'm her
because we're basically identical
and tell her later you did an amazing
job with that song Maggie it was
fabulous
[Music]
um but in seriousness uh I love she's
the one who brought my attention to the
song and had said like this is such a
great benediction song and I do just
want us to receive the these words as a
benediction I can't speak as a
benediction over us as we um close out
our service and then we'll still have
Don come up and close us with his normal
benediction but
um but the words of this song are just
so beautiful because I feel that they're
acknowledging both the pain and the hope
that can coexist together
um and I feel like that's a lot of what
lint is too it's acknowledging the pain
and the suffering of the Cross and yet
knowing that there is a hope that is
coming ahead
um so let's just receive this if we can
as Jesse sings it um and just focus on
the words
[Music]
a wish upon your peace
a wish upon you place
a Wish For Less of what you wanted more
of what you need
wish upon you an old life the heart that
stays Young
[Music]
wish upon you choose when all you feel
is down
I hope you know that an open mind still
knows when
when the wish upon you baby
[Music]
us
through weaving in the Darkness
[Music]
a wish upon you an easy life a wish upon
your hard times
[Music]
so even in the darkness you
you'll find
love
[Music]
yes even in the Darkness
you'll find the light
[Music]
thank you worship team that was great
um just a quick couple reminders um I
kind of mentioned to you guys earlier
the service next week if you would find
donating some eggs some candy for the
kids ministry for the recent Easter egg
hunt uh that we're gonna be doing for
Easter would really appreciate that
um and everything if you're a visitor
thank you so much for joining us there
is a box on the way out that door on
your right there's a place where you can
just leave your name and just some basic
contact information slip it in that box
that's on the side we just liked it
though have a record that you're here
and just to send you a word thanks for
just joining us this evening also if you
want to support this ministry you can
also put your donation there as well or
go online and donate online on the
website as well but with all that being
said if you want to stand and receive
this benediction
thank you
so you are a child of God
you are a child of God
and this is true on your best thing and
it's true on your worst day
so as you go into your week whether it's
you have to determine highs and lows and
everything in between
go filled with the assurance that you
are loved that you are worthy and then
you are accepted Just As You Are
and go filled with God's Holy Spirit and
the desire to extend these same Gifts of
Grace and unconditional love with
everyone you come in contact with
thank you and have a good
week
[Music]
yes even in the Darkness
next time if I ever play it again I'm
might hit that G right on